el regulador de los medios de
comunicación rusos ha advertido hoy a
youtube de que se expone a ser prohibido
en todo el territorio ruso si no
desbloquea los canales en alemán de la
televisión rusa rt estos canales fueron
censurados por youtube después de que
fuesen acusados de difundir fake news
sobre el coronavirus el ministro ruso de
asuntos exteriores sérguei lávrov ha
publicado un comunicado en el que
denuncia que está censura por parte de
youtube de los canales de rt se trata de
un ataque sin precedentes a la libertad
de información pero esta guerra de
medios que está volviendo a empezar
entre rusia y occidente no es nueva este
mismo mes el gobierno ruso consiguió con
sus presiones que las plataformas de
google y apple retirarse de sus tiendas
online una aplicación del líder opositor
ruso alexéi navalni el gobierno ruso
acusó entonces a google y apple de estar
a sueldo de gobiernos extranjeros